hi my name is Kelly chambers I'm an
astrologer based in Los Angeles and I'm
about to guess these wonderful BuzzFeed
employees signs an astrologer places a
lot of meanings a lot of meaning in the
placement of the planets at the time of
birth so basically we have a Zodiac
wheel it's basically a snapshot of the
sky at the moment you have that one
enters the world and based on the
aspects the houses that those planets
occupy that will tell something of the
character the challenges the gifts of
that individuals there's a lot of ways
to pick up energy without that can
obfuscate the Sun sign so this is
definitely a challenge but like it'd be
a really strong pure expression of that
sign so to get one out of 12 although we
have narrowed it down a little bit here
we'll see what happens all right I'm
gonna start with my most difficult
challenge okay he's okay I'm actually
just some random questions it's kind of
you know pop Corning all over the place
what is something that people tell you
about yourself that you're like I don't
I don't really drive with that I don't
know because I feel like compliments
other people or insults to me insults to
you or people tell you nice or sweet or
so yeah but I feel like sometimes super
are like oh like you're overly friendly
and I don't think that's very true of
Who I am but again insults that I don't
take as an insult as sometimes people
say I'm like Curt or like really short
really short like very direct yeah and
you consider yourself a competitive
person I would consider myself a
competitive person in terms of like I
have an addictive personality so it's
like I like to win okay you like to win
yeah in interpersonal relationships you
find that you are the aggressor do you
go after people are you a little bit
more coquettish or coy and let the you
know the man pursue I feel like I don't
really do the pursuing they come to me
but like very rarely do like I accept oh
pretty yeah wrong barrier there what do
you really want your life to be about
and what would you really regret I feel
like if I didn't like leave an
impression okay like if I was like oh
like 80s she was here
you won't like to be remarkable you
ought to be remembered you want to like
leave a legacy look remarkable but like
something cuz I don't want to like
be like a Wallflower you want to be a
standout in some way I want to be like
someone remembered give a best friend
yes what's her sign my oldest best
friend is Horace your oldest best friend
is a Taurus yeah so I get that you're
you don't like being called overly
friendly or sweet seems like you value
being direct being strong kind of
leaving a mark being remembered does
something be necessarily for something
important or life-changing or you know
are you a kind of extreme when you do
something to go all the way I would say
like if it holds my attention then I
like go all the way through you think
you're more kind of routine or do you
like a big throne all you kind of like
mmm no I like controlled chaos so I like
having my routine but I like they're
being room okay and routine for
spontaneity all right well I think I
have enough to guess I'm not gonna guess
all right
okay what about Nate what are some
things that you like that you look to or
and also reasons you said absolutely not
to somebody my two biggest ones I guess
our kindness and intelligence okay I
want them to be nice to me
are you know how did the last one end it
was going for a little bit and I wasn't
really feeling it so I broke it off what
have you been accused of that you're
surprised I was like Oh Nate you're so
this you're like wait what people tell
me I'm childish you like you're childish
yeah I like that are you someone that
has childish interests lots of interests
are you sort of all over the place or do
you kind of more coming up your pace I'm
a bit more grounded I kind of just pick
something and then focus on it and then
when I get bored I move on and tell me
what is the last thing that you were
interested in I got recently really into
making bread so I'm taking a lot of
bread
that's so cool are you someone who likes
like the domestic art so you can embody
I don't know about homebody but I do
like cooking a lot cooking and cleaning
you do like cooking and cleaning yeah
what's it like when you walk into a room
I always got a warm up to stuff so when
I walk into a room I gotta like look and
see what's going on and then
and where I'm gonna fit in you could see
yourself like an emotional do you like
lead with the heart you like very
sensitive I don't know if I'm sensitive
I do care a lot about what other people
think that's good and you like kindness
like you kind of like people to feel
safe yeah man you're a little bit
enigmatic oh that's good it's good but
you do relate strongly with your sign I
do there's like a couple traits to it
that I feel are like defining
characteristics okay all right that's
that's how far we're gonna go okay so
you Aidan if I stronger with your sign
idea okay tell me about like what poem
means to you oh I love to feel safe okay
and I love to be around energy have you
ever been accused of being impulsive I
have what would be the three qualities
that your best friend would like tell
you about yourself
loyal hard-working okay and friendly
what do you think like your big life
lesson is like what is something that's
been a little bit of a blind spot for
you I guess like the last year I've
gotten really into wellness and
mindfulness and then uhm a big life
lesson that I feel like I've learned is
just to live in the moment I mean it's
one of my struggles I tend to think too
much in the future I have to like live
in the moment and I get too caught up in
the details are you kind of a
perfectionist are you like really is
there a way like if the job doesn't get
done in a certain way doesn't really
kind of work you are you someone who
like prides yourself unlike other
collections you're sure a perfectionist
yeah what would be your the worst
criticism of course criticism thump
someone could throw at you I guess being
a bad person being a bad person yeah I
would never want to be called a bad
person ever how do you feel about
conflict
you get fiery or would you rather kind
of avoid it I do get fiery but I don't
like conflict like me for me so hard
working law I mean loyal friendly you
have been accused of being impulsive
which is interesting
I do like keeping a routine yeah you're
like kind of neat like you're ordered
but I like to have fun too
I think sometimes people think I don't
have fun right look at this look at this
blouse I wear I have fun all right
destiny of course there's one me like
you're leo
you're wild your hair and your lipstick
and you look like a lion as far as you
walking into a room or a party how do
you kind of feel at the room where you
tend to find yourself by the end of the
night I definitely search the room for
people I know that stick to them would
you consider yourself an introvert yes
and I can't be an introvert but I can
also show out if you can to the extent
you know yourself like name your values
like what is that you truly want to
cultivate or are proud of I definitely
want to make a difference in people's
life I wanna make a difference in
people's lives and all that's positively
what's kind of your if you if you know
your relationship is signature do you
feel confident around them do you feel
like it takes a long time to get to know
you
I'm a very fake it till you make it so
you may yeah like I'm very shy but I
come off very bold how do you feel about
yeah impulsivity surprises I love
surprises
you love surprises okay and you like
kind of glamorous things big things I
would not mind it you would not mind I
would not mind being the center of
attention
okay not my goal what's a side of your
personality that that we don't see I
guess being vulnerable vulnerable you do
have like a fiery presence every teens
not so important you I feel like you're
like a bold oh no I need a routine you
do what's been your greatest achievement
oh man I'm getting warmed up
I would say Furby person my greatest
achievement was going to college for
free that's a huge accomplishment okay
thank you thank you Joe okay so we have
Elena okay so let's just go right into
it are you in a relationship no it's
your relationship signatures Amit tell
me a little bit about how that works or
maybe what your last heartbreak was
about I like people who don't want me oh
you do you're gonna bail believe we were
like emotionally unavailable or okay
otherwise yeah are you a little bit of
an extremist do you go after you go
after them a little bit more yes I need
like huge amounts of attention and
validation okay like astronomical
amounts okay attention invalidation I'm
not necessarily someone who pursues
actively I will set up steps so that
like things will progress but it was
never quite like over you'll be kind of
strategic about it I will be like your
teacher like place yourself in
like position where they'll see you or
like oh girl yeah if I want to be seen I
will be seeing okay tell me about sports
competition I hate competition you hate
competition I hate games no why is that
cuz you don't feel like you're doing
them right cuz you just don't have the
physical vitality I am personally not
competitive and I don't like when other
people in team settings depend on you to
do well because I don't want to
disappoint them by not doing well it's
interesting so you're kind of protecting
yourself from being criticized and you
do identify with your sign
I identify so strongly with my sign and
I will tell you I I don't know if I can
but I will tell you I'm a triple you're
all one sign god I'm gonna be a big
failure if I don't get your sign okay
well thank you thanks for being so open
and honest okay so do you feel kind of
jovial kind of light-hearted what's the
role of kind of playfulness and
childishness in your in your life I feel
like I'm very outgoing okay with the
right people
I'm very vibrant yeah happy do people
keep your interests do boyfriends keep
your interest do you get a little bored
yeah and what what is what is it what's
the what's the boring part what is they
think it's because they're not like
passionate enough I'm very passionate
you like oh you're sending full
emotional basically happy they're kind
of at the kind of like rights that are
bringing it yeah like tell me about food
family home I love food my family is
very loud what do you feel about the
high volume chaos loud like is that fine
yeah what do you value what's like the
mood you value
in your home fun fun and lively and my
joking okay I'm gonna say your fire I
don't know it's so my first guess was
destiny leo and he's Ares question mark
Isla cancer Nate Virgo Elena
t4 Taurus and Maya g4 Gemini that might
all change but that was just my when I'm
just trying to not be to have too much
information so now my final guess is
this is gonna make or break my business
here we go I'm gonna say Taurus Elena
I'm gonna say Gemini Isla I'm gonna say
your Virgo and then we have destiny I'm
gonna say Leo Maya I'm gonna go with
Ares Nate cancer okay here we go your
cancer okay so I got the Ares alright
well not terrible Jim and I I find them
their interests in a thousand different
things and there's a real yeah like you
just seem so so focused and wizened I am
a little bit like oh don't judge a book
by it's cover
[Music]